Salut Vanessa
Ô
Le poussin que j'ai fait bouge l'animal brut
incarné dans la justice si tu espères me voir
Je vais m'arrêter avec ce sont les
principaux conflits moins c'est ça
tu sais tu sais que ceux-là rempliront ça pour
Globo pas complice
va conquérir Thunder en tant que complice
quelqu'un qui m'accompagne
non mais c'est mieux Messi ou toi Johnny
Johnny Johnny ne peut en choisir qu'un
C'est
je peux quitter les zones à risque, j'y vais
Johnny demande de fuir le premier samba
cours moelleux qui s'avère populaire mais c'est pour
un médecin retire le Bayern pour Juninho
coule sur le meilleur juge
de Justice inscrivent d'autres à
quoi
ne sois pas sexuel
comme complices
complices
sur une
chérie Johnny Somberland Jones va bien
mieux que d'être le premier état Rubio
Seigneur sois avec toi, commence et pars
voir tout Juninho est meilleur Richard Gere
pour Renault déjà lié au côté a
sac et pour connaître les problèmes que je
J'entendais mieux crier aux gardes
mais il n'y a aucun de nous
se conformer à ce Globo pas en complice
Tu sais que tant que tu es complice
complices
ET là